hello everybody my name is Ryan Johnson
and I'm a data science advisor here at
posit and Welcome to our first ever
Enterprise Community Meetup where we'll
discuss an end-to-end data science
workflow using posit team
so this will be a recurring event we'll
probably have it the last Wednesday of
every month and we hope it'll serve as a
good primer for those that are new to
posit team but also help current posit
team users become more familiar with our
tools
and every month we'll cover a different
topic and we'll highlight all three
tools within posit team so positive
workbench posit connect and posit
package manager
and then after each presentation we'll
have a casual discussion where folks can
ask us questions posit questions or we
can just discuss workflows with other
community members
so with that let's go ahead and get
started and I first want to start and
make sure that everyone on a call is
familiar with positive from a high level
so this is positive team and we're going
to start up here at the top with the
data scientist the data analysts the
folks that are actually writing code
and many times their job is to create
insights and to share those insights so
let's start by going to the left here
and creating insights they're going to
be writing code they can use R python
they can use whatever IDE they want
either our studio Jupiter lab jupy
notebooks vs code all within posit
workbench so posit workbench is our
server-based implementation of the
various Ides
and your data scientists are writing
code again in whatever language they
want so if you're with an R they might
be creating things like shiny
applications pins are marked down
plumber but if they're python developers
they might be creating things like flask
or fast apis streamlit Dash bokeh
applications Jupiter notebooks maybe
they're also creating quarto documents
which is one of our newest tools
so when they create content like this it
doesn't do anyone any good if they can't
share it with the people that need to
see it and that's the whole purpose of
posit connect our second tool within
posit team this is our professional
publishing platform and this makes it
super easy to share all the cool content
you see here with the people that need
to see it like your boss decision makers
maybe your yourself maybe your friends
or family you can share it with posit
connect
so for today's session we're primarily
going to live within posit workbench and
posit connect but there's also one other
tool we'll touch upon today and that's
posit package manager and it does pretty
much as it name its name implies it
helps control all those great open
source packages with an r and python
also any you know packages you've
created yourself within workbench and
connect so we'll talk about all three of
these tools today that again round out
pause it team
now for today's session we are actually
going to live within vs code so we're
going to go into posit workbench and
we're going to open up a vs code session
and we're going to go through an example
where we take a dash application it's
actually a dashboard we're going to
publish it to posit connect and share it
with everyone here on the line
so we're going to again primarily live
within workbench and connect today and
then we'll touch upon package manager
so this dash application is actually
built into our jump start examples
you'll find when you first log into
posit connect
so when you log in you can click on r or
python so here I have python selected
and you can see a variety of other
examples but we're going to create this
stock pricing dashboard which is a dash
application
and this is just a screenshot of what
some of that content looks like within
that Dash application so again we're
looking at stock prices we'll have a few
different stocks you can choose from and
we'll get the chance to explore this
application once we actually deploy it
so with that let's go ahead and get
started
so I'm going to be leveraging our demo
server here at posit we have our three
professional tools right here
and let's go ahead and start within
posit workbench so I'm going to go ahead
and open this up in a new tab
and when you first log into posit
workbench this is the screen you're
going to see all right on the right hand
side I have various our studio projects
that I've been working on and I can
easily click on one of them and jump
right back in or I can start up a brand
new session so let's go ahead and do
that
and this again is one of the best parts
about posit workbench is that no matter
what your data science team uses their
preferred IDE the hope is that we can
support it here within positive
workbench so we currently support
jupyter notebook jupyter lab we have the
rstudio IDE as well and then we have the
vs code editor which is a great
all-purpose editor which is what we're
going to use today so I'm going to click
on vs code
and when we do that we get some
additional options so I can give this vs
code session a name I'll just leave it
as a default right here
and then right underneath you're going
to see cluster kubernetes now to tell
you a little bit more about our demo
environment here at posit it is all
hosted in AWS Amazon web services
and it's in a high performance Computing
cluster an HPC environment and that
environment is managed using something
known as kubernetes so some of you may
have heard of kubernetes that's one of
these HPC managers that we support if
you also use slurm we can support that
as well or you can also just run these
tools on a single server that's totally
fine as well
but one of the advantages of using
kubernetes or slurm is you can actually
control this job CPU and memory
allocations so if you just have like a
small job you want to maybe create a
plot or a simple application you can
keep the CPU low keep the memory low and
that's just great for managing compute
resources
but if you have a higher compute a more
demanding job I can bump that up for
example I can change the memory as well
so really good at managing resources
then you'll see this last box right here
and this is uh the image box so I have
the option to choose a specific Docker
image here to deploy this session so
that can help control additional
environment variables things like what
our versions are available python
versions what packages are installed by
default that can all be controlled using
various Docker images but I'll just
stick to the default for right now
that all looks good let's go ahead and
start the session
so once I do that you can see this
session is starting and one of the other
advantages of posit workbench is if I
want to start another session the exact
same time I can do that I can have more
than one vs code session going I can
have in our studio session going I can
have a Jupiter we'll open a Jupiter
notebook session going and this is a
great way if you're working on multiple
projects using different languages and
different Ides you can have them all
going simultaneously and easily switch
between the four that I've created here
so we're going to open up this first vs
code session you can see down here at
the bottom
and we'll just have that ready once we
get the dash application going here
all right so here is vs code again
running on posit workbench on the left
hand side we see my file explorer and
I've already created a blank directory
there's nothing in it I just called it
quick start and this is where we're
going to house that Dash application
we're eventually going to deploy
and then we have that get started guide
that pops up I'll go ahead and just
close out of that
all right so we are ready we're ready to
create this dash application and
eventually deploy it to posit connect
so where are we going to find this Dash
application
so coming back to our demo environment a
posit team here we've already started
within workbench let's go ahead and open
up posit connect
so when you click on posit connect or
open up posit connect you'll see this
screen that pops open these are our jump
start examples right here
and you can see there's a variety of
content for r related content so our
markdown parameterize our markdown
plumber API shiny apps pins
um you can choose any of these to get
started you can also select various
python content that's supported by
connect so Jupiter notebooks Dash bokeh
streamlit uh various other ones python
shiny application which is one of our
newest supported applications
what word for today's uh demo we're
actually going to stick with this stock
pricing dashboard and probably for
future sessions we'll probably focus on
some of these other jumpstart examples
but we thought this would be a great
place to start
so we're going to go ahead and we're
going to
send this like or download this dash
application we'll put it on pause it
workbench and then we'll deploy it to
posit connect so let's go ahead and get
started
so with the jumpstart examples the first
thing that we need to do is we need to
download the files for this dash
application so we have it on this
download button I'm going to download it
to my computer
and then I'll click on next right here
and it says to unzip this file that we
just downloaded locally and then we can
[Music]
basically move on to the next step but
I'm going to go ahead and open this up
within posit workbench so let me switch
back over to vs code again running
within posit workbench I'm going to grab
that file that I just downloaded and I'm
going to drag it over here to my file
directory
and now we have that zip file that I
just downloaded from that jumpstart
example within vs code on posit
workbench
now the first thing we need to do is
unzip this file and gather all of its
contents and we're going to do this
using the terminal so I'm going to click
on this button the top left corner I
like to call it a burger button click on
that you'll see terminal new terminal
all right if I do print working
directory just to see what directory I'm
in you can see I'm in that quick start
directory
and if I do LS to list all the files in
that directory it just has that single
zip file so let's go ahead and unzip it
so I'm going to run unzip and then we'll
just give it the name of that zipped
file and hit enter
and that's actually going to when it
unzips the content is within a separate
directory called stock dashboard python
so I'm going to go ahead and navigate
into that directory so CD to change the
directory stock dashboard python
now I'm going to clear my screen I can
do that on my keyboard using control l
if I do print working directory now you
can see I'm within that directory that
file that we just unzipped and I can
click on it right here and we can see
all the contents and right here app.pi
this is the dash application that we are
going to run and deploy to posit connect
all right so let's come back to posit
connect and keep working our way through
those steps to the jumpstart example
the first thing we need to do is install
the required packages using something
known as pip which is a typical
installer for installing python packages
and we're going to use pip to install
all the packages that live inside this
file
requirements.txt so let me come back to
vs code and just show you what that file
looks like so over here on the left hand
side you can see requirements.txt
these are all the libraries the python
libraries that I need to basically run
this Dash application and the necessary
versions all right so this is kind of a
good for my environment making sure that
all these are present to appropriately
deploy this Dash application
so let's go ahead and make sure all
these packages are there
I'm going to copy this command from the
jumpstart example come back to vs code
hit paste and enter
it's going to print some logs to my
screen you can see a lot of these say
requirement already satisfied so that's
good it looks like that these packages
for the most part were already present
in my environment
but I want to take a quick pause here
and I think it's worth noting or trying
to determine where am I actually looking
when I go to install these packages
and that's where package manager
positive package manager is going to
come into play so if you look on this
line right here looking in indexes it
provides a URL this is actually a URL to
our demo posit package manager instance
so let me come back to our demo
environment and let's explore package
manager a little bit
now for the most part package manager is
a tool used by your system
administrators or it team to help set up
the package environment for workbench
for connect for your developers but
there is a user interface that
developers can log into and see what
packages are available to them so let's
get started
so here's the user interface and I first
want to have everyone take a look on the
left hand side
over here you can see various R
repositories that are set up in this
instance of package manager so things
like a cran mirror for example or any
internally developed R packages
we also conserve bioconductor packages
so if anyone's doing any genomic
analysis High throughput data sequencing
data analysis you might be familiar with
bioconductor but for today's demo we're
going to focus in on python repos and
there's currently two in this example
package manager instance we see Pi Pi
and local python
so just to describe what local python is
if you're creating any of your own
python packages and you want to share
them with your team you can upload them
to your instance of package manager and
make it super easy for anyone else on
your team and your company to leverage
that package
and then you see Pi Pi
and Pi Pi is one of the largest
repositories for python packages and you
can explore all the various packages
currently within Pi Pi so for example I
can search numpy which is a pretty
popular data science package within
python
we can get some information about it
like how to install it what it requires
so python the conversion has to be
greater than 3.8 what's the most recent
version and some other information as
well
but how do I pull in numpy from this
instance of package manager from this Pi
Pi repository so by selecting Pi Pi you
can see the name right here in the top
left corner
we're going to go to the setup Tab and
talk a little bit more about how to
leverage package manager
so I'm going to scroll down just a
little bit here
and you're going to see this URL use
this URL to receive the latest Source
packages so when you go to install a
package if you install from this URL
it's going to pull in from this
repository on your instance of package
manager and for example this is our
again our demo environment of posit
package manager
and then to Just note a few other cool
things you can do with package manager
you can see in the path here latest by
using this URL I'm always going to pull
in the latest and greatest version of
numpy for example
but maybe that's not exactly what you
want to do maybe you have a project that
you worked on you know a year ago and
you want to go back into that project
and you want to install packages as they
were a year ago and that's where this
calendar comes into play so I can go all
the way back
let's say December 1st 2021
if I click on that date you can see the
URL has changed and now the date is
reflected in the path and if I install a
package using this URL it'll install it
as if it's December 1st 2021.
and then if you ever want to learn how
to actually leverage this URL in your
instance of vs code or wherever you're
doing your python development we have
some instructions right down here to
install one-off packages from package
manager or have it set more persistently
so any package you ever install will
always use this URL and that's what I
pretty much done in my environment
so that's package manager so let's come
back here to
connect so we've already done this stuff
we've installed all these packages we
made sure they're available available
using this requirements.txt file
let's move on to the next step
and now we're going to install this RS
connect python package this is the
actual package that's used to deploy
python content to posit connect and
we're going to install it using pip
again so pip install RS connect python
package so I'm going to go ahead and
copy this command come back to vs code
I'm going to clear my screen just to
make it a little bit cleaner so Ctrl L
I'm going to hit paste and hit enter
foreign
you can see it's pulling from that same
instance of posit package manager in our
demo environment and for the most part
looks like everything that this package
depends on the package itself was
already satisfied it's already present
in my environment so that's great
so I'll clear my screen here come back
to connect and let's move on to the next
step
which is really the last step we are
going to go ahead and deploy this
application using the RS connect python
package
now there's a note right here you will
need to create and use an API key in
order to deploy your python application
and this is important because when you
deploy to posit Connect using this
package the RS connect python package
connect needs to know who's actually
trying to deploy and make sure you have
the necessary credentials and the
Privileges to actually deploy to that
instance of posit connect
so right here is the command that we're
going to use to deploy our dash
application I'm going to go ahead and
copy it
bring it on over to vs code again
running in posit workbench and just
paste it I'm not going to run it just
yet but let's run through this command
because it reads pretty easily from left
to right
so we're using that RS connect python
package so this uh function right here
to deploy a dash application to This
Server this instance of posit connect
and then you can see this next argument
API key and then there's some
placeholder text right here
so this is where you're going to supply
that API key to let connect know that
hey it's me deploying this dash
application to that instance of posit
connect
so where do we find this API key
let's go back to posit connect which
I've already logged into I'm going to
close out of this jumpstart example
because we're pretty much done with it
for the most part
and I'm going to go over here to the my
name in the top right corner
and you'll see API keys so you can click
on API keys and you can see I've already
created about four or so API keys if you
need to create a brand new one you just
select this box right here
copy that API key come on back over to
vs code running a positive workbench and
paste it right here
Now API Keys you should always treat
just like you would any passwords you
want to make sure they're nice and safe
I've actually already added this to my
environment so I'm just going to delete
this argument
and the RS connect python package will
automatically detect it when it runs
this command
and then the last little bit this Dot
and then the the forward slash right
here it ours connect will automatically
detect this app.pi application in the
directory and deploy it so that's it
this is the command we'll hit enter and
we'll let it run
so it looks like I may have so let me
just check the print working directory
I'm gonna try to come out one more time
oh I got delete the API key there we go
and hit enter
there we go so it's going through a few
checks right here like validating the
server making sure that bundle looks
good everything seems to be in order
okay if anything's not in order it
should print some nice useful messages
for you to help troubleshoot but what's
actually happening right now like when
you deploy this application what's going
on
so for the most part it's capturing my
environment it's looking to see what
python version am I using what libraries
am I using what versions of the library
so you can see like right here for
example all these various python
libraries and their Associated versions
it's making sure connect has those
packages and the appropriate versions on
the server and can replicate my
environment as exactly as it's laid out
here
once it's established it can it then
deploys that dash application so you can
see deployment completed successfully
and then it gives me two links right
here we'll select that top one
click on this
and it's going to bring us right to
posit connect
and while this is running kind of um
setting up right here you'll notice as a
publisher I have this little gear icon
in the top right corner and these are
some additional controls I have as a
publisher of this Dash application
but here it is this is the dash
application now hosted on posit connect
and we can try it out we can hover our
Mouse over here some of the plots you
can see a little pop-up I can choose
another stock so let's try Google you
can see that one pops up as well
scrolling down is a few other
interactive plots and visualizations so
here I could zoom in on a specific date
this spot's pretty cool I can select
certain points and you can see those
points being selected in the companion
plot right to the left here kind of a
cool crosstalk feature and then we also
have a table over here as well
so this is the dash application
now again as a publisher I have some
additional controls and the most
important thing is I'm a publisher how
do I then share it with the people that
need to see it
and that's going to be right here under
access controls
now we have it set by default to
specific users or groups and if you look
right underneath you can define those
users and groups right here
I'm currently the only one that can view
this content but let's say for example I
want to give Rachel access
now we would be the only two that can
view this content so really tight
control over who you want to share this
application with which is great
especially if you have any sensitive
data
but we can be a little less strict so if
you look at the middle option right here
all users login required if I select
this basically as long as you can log
into the connect instance you can view
this content
so here I pause it it's our demo
environment that's pretty much all
positive employees they can log into the
connect instance they can view it
but we can be even less strict and
select any one no login required
and if I do that basically this
application this dashboard we created
when hosted on connect is opened up to
the world so if anyone has this URL on
the top of the screen you see right here
they can view this content
now if you look at this URL you can see
it's not the prettiest URL just some
random letters and numbers up here we
can change that we can give this a more
customized URL so I can come down here
to content URL and I can just say Dash
app
and hit save
and now we have this customized URL at
the bottom of my screen which we can
then share with the world and anyone can
view this content
so let's talk about a few of the other
options you have again as con as a
publisher you have tight control over
this dash application the next one we'll
go to is runtime
and this is where you can control the
compute resources or python processes
supporting this application if it's a
real lightweight application doesn't
require a lot of compute power you can
keep it very low but if you have an
application that's maybe crunching some
large data or training a model for
example you might want to allocate some
additional python processes so there are
python processes supporting this
application while it's running we can
define a minimum number of processes
a maximum which you can see here is set
to three and then you have Max
connections per process now if I share
that link with somebody and they click
on that link they become a connection to
this application
so by default here I can have up to 50
connections and up to three processes so
I can support up to 150 concurrent users
now that may be perfect for what you
need maybe you want to tweak it and you
can do that again as a publisher you
don't have to worry about your
administrators and talking to them and
configuring it you can do it as a
publisher so for example I can come in
here and I can give it 10 more
additional processes
and then in this configuration I can
support up to 500 concurrent users so 50
connections per process and up to 10
processes
so again that's how you can control it
as a publisher
a few additional options here along the
top the scheduling tab this actually
does not apply to interactive content so
things like Dash streamlit bokeh or
within the our ecosystem like shiny
applications so scheduling jobs doesn't
necessarily apply to interactive content
but if you are deploying things like our
markdown or Jupiter notebooks or even
quarto documents you can actually Place
code in those documents and schedule
them to run
so this is great if you have any
recurring jobs maybe every morning when
you come in you can actually place them
into any of those documents I just
mentioned hosted on connect and you can
schedule it to run however frequently
you want
and then just to round out the last two
here tags is just for organizing your
content so if you have maybe a study or
a project you're working on and there's
a variety of pieces of content
associated with that project you can
create a tag to help easily organize and
pull up that various content types
and the last one here is vars
if your content requires some type of
privileged access to like a database or
an API for example you can come into the
vars tab right here and Supply that
password or API key so the application
has those credentials to access you know
that database or API for example
all right so that's pretty much it and
just to recap again
what we did today we started in posit
workbench we created that vs code
session we downloaded the dash
application from the jumpstart example
hosting connect so that stock example
and then we went through the process of
deploying that application to positive
connect and then sharing it with the
world and as we did that we were
installing packages from our instance of
posit package manager
so hopefully this positive team overview
was helpful and we're just going to go
ahead and open it up to any questions
from the audience General discussion and
we'd be happy to answer any questions
that anybody has